it's great to be joined today by rocky
Anderson a lawyer and former two-term
mayor of Salt Lake City Utah who left
the Democratic Party co-founded the
Justice Party in 2011 and was that
party's candidate for president in 2012
and we're going to get to that but I
want to start you you have this very
interesting story where you ran
unsuccessfully for House of
Representatives in Utah second district
in 96 and at the time the DNC didn't
fund you because they thought you were
too liberal and it's amazing what made
you too liberal at the time I mean tell
us some of the reasons that in 96 you
were too liberal for the Democratic
Party it's a bit Kafkaesque actually I
had been involved in a lot of community
organizations not really electoral
politics per se but just thought it was
time for a change there was an open seat
we had a district that hadn't been
gerrymandered like it is now so it
really was possible for a Democrat to
win that seat I entered the race and
local Democratic leaders came to me and
said oh you can't do that we told this
other guy that he was going to have it
all clear that he wasn't going to have a
competitive race in the primaries hmm
and I said and the one of the women who
was arguing with me about this was at
Utah as for choice an organization that
I helped found and I said wait a minute
guy you're supporting wants a
constitutional amendment to ban abortion
are you sure about this says yes at
least he'll talk to us and I said well
of course I'll always talk to you I
helped found the organization you work
with but they said we need somebody you
pointed out that I was former ACLU board
president but I opposed the death
penalty that I was pro-choice what else
hold that I was divorced our general had
to throw that in and so they said well
this guy's going to back out if you run
against him but we'll go find somebody
else so they went out and found who they
were looking for and that that that's a
core
to a pollster who told them to win this
race you've got to have somebody who is
a white male conservative Mormon I said
oh great so you you so religion sex and
conservatism are three of your four
criteria let's see why oh and race is
the fourth one of course
and I say you I'll go ahead because
you're you know this a lot better than I
do
you've been working party politics I'm
just a lawyers concerned about our
country and our community so go pick
your guy well they went and picked
somebody either you know as an
announcement he you said something like
I'm going to represent those who can't
represent theirselves and now that was
kind of typical and things would come up
during that race you'll remember in 1996
President Clinton signed Dolman the
so-called Defense of Marriage Act I
opposed that I said it's
unconstitutional and this guy told me on
the way out of a debate you know you
just lost if you win this primary you've
just lost the general election and I
said well that's all that's important to
you go for it but it is unconstitutional
now all these years later what happens
Obama tells his Attorney General
Solicitor General to take the position
the DOMA is unconstitutional yeah you
were right about that I was so I mean
it's it's very clear that in the twenty
in these twenty years
opposing the death penalty is no longer
controversial by and large in the
Democratic Party supporting the ACLU is
not controversial but still there are
real questions particularly after the
November 8th election about what it is
that the Democratic Party should or
should not do looking forward and what's
your sense of it as someone who has left
the Democratic Party David let me just
say this about that race yeah in the
general election I won very handily the
primary and running against my
Republican opponent he made my support
of same-sex marriage and consider this
1996 there weren't a lot of people
running who's supported marriage
equality at the time that was the core
his campaign and that's why I lost that
race mhm
was my support and all the Democrats
were running away as fast as they could
for me the Democratic Party here
wouldn't even mention my name in their
campaign literature and I see very much
the same happening now may not be the
same issues I mean Hillary Clinton
opposed marriage equality when I was in
favor of it in fact for many years after
I lost that race because of my position
for marriage equality
she only changed her position when the
polls said that it was okay to do that
and it's and President Obama as well by
the way remember his thinking was
evolving over all those years he said
but I think what we see is a very
cowardly Democratic Party they were
cowardly during the Bush years they were
cowardly during the Obama years imagine
what the Democratic Party would have
done if George Bush or any other
Republican had been in office and he was
holding his terror tuesday meetings in
his Oval Office putting together a list
of people to be assassinated including
US citizens well because it was a
Democrat in office there were no
Democrats speaking up about this the
same thing with regard to accountability
for torture accountability for all the
lies dragging us into the war and I
think a lot of people have very short
memories but the two secretaries of
state under President Obama John Kerry
and Hillary Clinton both voted and
helped pass the lies concerning the war
against Iraq and I think that's
absolutely unconscionable the people
ought to be held accountable when you
vote for worry I don't know what you're
talking about instead Hillary Clinton
especially went out and gave speeches
perpetuating these lies being told to us
by the bush administration so talk to us
a little bit about the Justice Party in
what ways I think the most interesting
thing to see would be in what ways does
the Justice Party differ from the
Democratic Party well first of all we
are very very concerned about the
corrupting influence of money and
politics
and we hear almost nothing from the
Democratic Party about major campaign
finance reform now because they are
feeding at the same trough of special
interest money that the Republicans have
been feeding from the Democratic Party
has become the party of Wall Street
they're sponsored by the financed ears
when President Obama first ran for
office he received more from Wall Street
than any candidate had before and then
Hillary Clinton was getting her pre
bribes from firms like Goldman Sachs by
going and speaking before she even
started running for president it was
what two years ago this last October
she was pocketing hundreds of thousands
of dollars from Goldman Sachs for giving
a couple of speeches and those are pre
bribes these folks know what they're
doing they knew what they could do with
President Clinton it was a former
Goldman Sachs CEO that was his Treasury
Secretary the god President Clinton to
repeal glass-steagall which I think was
devastating to our economy and to do
away with the regulation of derivatives
and the Commodity Futures Modernization
Act of 2000 these these these kinds of
actions by the Democratic Party simply
are a betrayal especially the middle
class and the poor in this country and
to our economy generally in the economy
worldwide because it helps lead to this
disaster that we experienced and a lot
of people really haven't recovered from
so and the other thing is their support
for not not only unnecessary Wars but
illegal wars of aggression there when
President Clinton was secretary there's
excuse me Hillary Clinton was Secretary
of State
we're bombing Libya making sure there's
regime change but they had no plan
President Obama said it was the biggest
mistake of his administration that they
had no plan in place for what was going
to happen after they went over and
basically invaded in a certain sense I
heíd Libya and then what we did in Syria
there was no constitutional compliance
by Congress there it was the president
going off on his own completely contrary
to the War Powers Clause of our
Constitution and completely contrary to
international law honey of the United
Charter one last thing I want to touch
on it we do a very limited time but I
want to get your thought on I know that
you were you were born into a Mormon
family but are no longer Mormon you've
expressed significant concerns over the
the church's prior treatment of black
Americans particularly before they were
allowed to be priests what's it like
living in Salt Lake City as a former
Mormon is that is there anything unusual
about that or notable people in the LDS
Church look down upon people leaving the
religion but I think a lot of people
know of my commitment to our community
my commitment to principle and I have a
lot of LDS friends but Salt Lake City is
actually a very progressive City mm-hmm
and that's why I was able to win by a
20% margin when I first ran for mayor
and then I won by a smaller margin when
I ran for re-election but that's after I
was calling for the impeachment of
President Bush and speaking out all over
the country against the Iraq war and
doing a lot internationally on issues
like climate change so I we got a lot
done when I was mayor but I think that
it it was a perfect case example of how
if you stick by your principles people
will respect it and you can get a lot
done you don't need to keep cowering
like this Democratic Party has been
doing where they're basically
unrecognizable from the Republican Party
on so many of these issues that matters
so much in our everyday lives matters of
peace and war the the tremendous
disparity in income and wealth greater
than at any time since the Gilded Age in
the late 1800s Democrats are part and
parcel of that and if you look at Thomas
Frank's book listen liberal he paints
the whole history of this evolution of
what was once can
the People's Party - now the party of
Wall Street and party of war yep great
book we interviewed Thomas Frank not too
long ago we've been speaking with rocky
Anderson former two-term mayor of Salt
Lake City thanks so much for talking to
me today great to be with you thanks a
lot